Однобічне розширення Вашингтоном санкцій проти Москви викликало різку критику з боку Брюсселя та Берліна.
На це є кілька причин, найголовніші - в огляді DW.
Протидію посиленим санкціям США проти Росії європейські чиновники пояснюють можливими потрясіннями на енергетичному ринку Європи
Брюссель занепокоєний тим, що великі європейські енергетичні компанії, що ведуть бізнес з Росією
такі як Shell, Eni та BP - відчують санкції на собі, зокрема, через обмеження доступу до кредитів американських банків.
А це може вдарити по стратегічних інвестиціях та поставити під загрозу енергетичну безпеку континенту.
Особливо занепокоєні через рішення Вашингтона у Німеччині, яка є одним з ключових учасників проекту "Північний потік-2".
У фінансуванні трубопроводу задіяні  французька Engie, англо-голландська Shell, австрійська OMV, а також німецькі Uniper та Wintershall.
Цей проект передбачає поставки блакитного палива дном Балтійського моря з Росії до Німеччини, а далі в інші країни ЄС - в обхід України та Польщі.
Думки оглядачів щодо цього розділилися.
Одні вважають, що цим законом США прагнуть зменшити енергетичну залежність Європи від Росії і водночас захистити свої економічні інтереси
замінивши російський природний газ американським зрідженим.
Натомість інші наголошують, що потреби у "Північному потоці-2" взагалі немає.
Європа не проти санкцій як таких, але вони небули узгоджені із західними союзниками США
та не враховували їхні інтереси – це і не сподобалося Європі.
У Берліні пояснили: не можуть прийняти те, що США використовує обмеження проти Росії як інструмент економічної політики.
"America first". Америка, звісно, передусім, заявив голова Єврокомісії Жан-Клод Юнкер, але це не означає, що інтереси ЄС мають бути позаду.